Car tester Emmanuel Schäfer notes that the
station wagon version of BMW's 5 series has
been around for 25 years now.
And this is the fifth generation.
The designers first revamped the sedan, then
the touring car.
We're testing the 530 with a 195-kilowatt
diesel engine.
It launches from zero to 100 in 5-point-8
seconds.
BMW says it consumes just under 6 liters of
fuel per 100 kilometers.
The fronts of the touring car and the sedan
are identical.
Both speak the new BMW design language: visually,
the kidney-shaped radiator grilles and the
headlights are a single unit.
One of the station wagon's innovations is the
stub axle, which allows a flat cargo floor.
It also widens the cargo area and increases
the maximum cargo weight to 720 kg.
Emmanuel says many customers chose the 5 touring
car over other station wagons in its segment
because of its two-part hatch.
That hasn't changed in the fifth generation.
So you can open the top of the tailgate and
drop in your shopping bags -- easy!
So no having to heave up the weight of the
whole tailgate, or wait for it to open electronically.
The standard pneumatic suspension smooths
the ride on uneven roadways, and the revised
station wagon cuts a good figure overall on
country roads.
But how does it perform on the highway?
The 5 series touring car is often used for
long trips or vacations, says Emmanuel, and
BMW had that in mind when looking for things
to improve.
First was driver comfort.
BMW took a look at the suspension and decided
to replace some parts with lighter ones.
And then there's the noise level in the interior.
BMW added more insulation without adding much
weight.
Emmanuel thinks the results are convincing.
This generation of the 5 station wagon is
noticeably quieter than its predecessor.
That makes driving more pleasant, even at
high speeds.
You can drive several hundred kilometers without
having your head throb from all the noise
when you get out of the car at the end of
your journey.
There's another thing Emmanuel likes: You
know how when you set off on a winter morning,
and it's cold in the car -- and your hands
get cold?
But who wants to wear gloves in the car?!
Of course, many manufacturers have steering
wheel heating.
But where do they put the control?
You often spend a long time looking for it.
Sometimes it's on the right of the central
console, sometimes on the left below the steering
wheel, sometimes somewhere else.
BMW put the button in the logical place -- in
the lower middle of the steering wheel.
Just turn it on and your hands warm up.
A simple solution -- but you have to think
of it first.
That's practical for people who often drive
different vehicles -- plus, you don't have
to take your eyes off the road to turn the
heating on or off.
Emmanuel says BMW has made lots of little
improvements to the 5-series station wagon.
It still isn't the top of its segment for
trunk volume, but it DOES hold more than its
predecessor.
The 530d version he tested starts at just
under 57,000 euros in Germany.